sometimes I create the sort of
characters that I'm I'm afraid of when I
was like you're afraid of yeah when I
was a kid I there was a guy who maybe
the first of the modern serial killers a
guy named Charlie Stark with and I had a
scrapbook I cut out all these clippings
of him and my mother found this
scrapbook it was 57 so I would have been
about 10 years old and I think she
decided right then and there that not
all my wheels were on the road anymore
and she said why are you interested in
this guy what I was not able to tell her
was there was one picture of this young
man who killed these people and what the
was in his eyes was nothing at all I
mean vacant room depopulated planets
there's nothing and what I was not able
to tell her was I need to look out for
this guy and in my fiction when I've
created characters like uh John rainberg
and Firestarter or George Stark in the
dark half some of the real bad guys I'm
telling myself reminding myself look out
for these guys these guys are dangerous
and they're really out there